precision precision
this has to get over there
but when you're strong you can't lift
your hand off
and you've only got very short space of
time but unless
unless his hand is looking like that
you haven't got it if it's if it's like
that
you're going to need strength to try to
unwind that this
all you do is you go i need this hand
for a moment so i'm just going to hold
you there while i take that out
then remember what i said about the
first coke in that uh coca-dozer
i'm not going to cut him down
because that means i'm going to do it
straight forward you go
so here
this
you start the bottom of his neck and you
roll it away
i think um the other week i was here i
was talking about bicycle paddles um
when we were doing the lady and that you
know the ikea
one
two
away
don't bring it back into you or else it
means your ego has to be satisfied that
you can do the technique
push him hard
good see here is no good now it's going
to need strength so if i get it out he's
not going to go anywhere
so you have to really turn that like
that
so you're going to need strength or
something
to do that's it
that's
your mind into that
this hand doesn't come across 10 minutes
later
and doing this
it comes across in a flash
i'll show you the whole thing
okay
it can't come across 10 minutes later
it can't go well oh i haven't got it so
it's got to be all at once this one's
going to help pin
it down
that's true